hi there steve kaufman and today i want
to talk to you about
starting a new language hebrew and i'm
going to talk a bit about the hebrew
alphabet
because i can because to me learning
languages is about listening and reading
so i want to be able to read the
language so my first task
is to learn how to read so i come
right up against the hebrew alphabet so
i'm going to talk a bit about my
experiences first of all
why learn hebrew
um you know i'm going to be in israel
initially i had said that uh or i told
myself i just work on greek because i
thought it would be too tough to try and
learn hebrew between now and october
so i've been working on greek for the
last three months or so
and doing it still doing it
uh but then you know i was reminded you
know i'm gonna be in israel i won't be
able to read anything i don't like that
feeling
and in fact uh you'll see that right
after this video i've tacked on another
video that uh connor klein did with me
in la vie where i talk about when you
travel having the language is that
fourth dimension it adds so much to your
visit so
even if i can get a little bit of a
start in the hebrew before going there
while maintaining my greek i want to try
to do it
so i'm going to get started doing hebrew
i announced it on august the 4th on
twitter
so the first thing i come across of
course is the hebrew alphabet
so i
looked up on the internet and i found a
website that had the
hebrew alphabet so i printed that out
but
i mean it's very hard to try to learn an
alphabet alphabet by looking at lists
so
um i had also
when i bought my greek living language
i'd also bought this
um living language hebrew but it's
really not a good system a very halter
skelter
and you know they introduced some helter
skelter words and phrases and
like on the very next page they say
let's practice the vocabulary you've
learned match the hebrew
in the left column with the english
equivalent on the right column i can't
even read the language how am i supposed
to do that why do these beginner books
set you on to quizzes and tests and
drills so quickly forget that
so
what i've been doing is i have been um
hitting these uh mini stories of ours
at link and
you know how much can i really achieve
because i you know i i just finished
while doing the dishes on my ipod i was
listening to the latest uh vashta
swaboda podcast from ukraine and
ukrainian
in another half hour i have a discussion
in russian with constantine and we're
going to talk about
how we're going to evolve uh lessons at
link and that we played golf today and
then my wife wants me to sit there and
watch this telenovela
blanca and she likes me to sit there
with her so i like i got no time
so if i get in an hour a day i don't
half an hour a day with and of course i
can't listen like normally i could be
listening but i can't listen to noise i
have to listen to something that i have
read
so all of that leads us up to what i've
been doing uh which is reading on um
on link here
and using the text to speech
hebrew the hebrew alphabet has some
significant problems for a learner
and
so you know these are the frustrations
and difficulties that you face when you
start in a language it doesn't matter
what it is
i'm sure hebrew is not the most
difficult language i'm sure that like
chinese you gotta learn all the
characters like every language has its
difficulties and when you start out the
difficulties seem overwhelming
but i know from experience that in time
things improve they don't get worse
so even though every day
i try and read this and i listen to the
text to speech and and then the next day
i try and read it and i i still can't
really read it and it's frustrating but
i know
that in time it'll get better so you
know
i look at it and of course behold the
problem in hebrew is
that um you know a lot of these letters
like behold book can sometimes be ver
and sometimes
you don't know they have in the hebrew
it's funny you know aside from the fact
that the hebrew alphabet is different
from anything i've seen
uh
although not as daunting to me as the
arabic script because the arabic script
is so
cursive and and and it seems to change
depending on where it's whether it's at
the beginning or the middle of the or
the end of a word
the hebrew script is a little more
straightforward
but you have letters that have can be
pronounced in several ways
you have some letters that are not
pronounced
but they look nice but they're not not
pronounced
uh some were letters that are pronounced
differently in the middle of a word and
then they're silent at the end of the
word
you have a letter like there's something
that looks like basically an i and it's
pronounced
in some situations and ooh in other
situations and then there are no vowels
so you don't know if it's b boba
now they do have uh
for non-native speakers they put in
these little microscopic dots that you
can hardly see that are supposed to in
some way give you a hint or tell you
what the vowel is i haven't gotten to
learn those yet because it turns out
these are only used for non-native
speakers and they're not used for normal
readers of the language so if i'm in
israel and i want to be able to read
what's going on i won't get these little
dots so i better get used to
this you know the writing system without
the vowels
uh so those are just some there are
letters that there's different letters
you know several letters that say that
uh are pronounced s
several letters that are pronounced t
as i say no vowels some are pronounced
differently depending on whether they
show up
uh where they show up so it's it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a it's a challenge
let's say
so what i do is you know i listen to it
okay
[Music]
see here it is pronounced
he's making breakfast
so every day i read a little i read a
little and uh i'm not yet at the point
where i could
uh take because this is recorded
you know
i could listen to the human voice
reading this but i don't understand a
thing
so i'm kind of stuck still trying to
learn to read
and i'm just going to read every day i
just read i'm patient it's so important
to be patient i know that if i read
every day and then i listen to the text
to speech for each word on each phrase
eventually it's going to get clearer i
already am able to read better than i
was two three days ago so it's just a
question of putting in the time
uh
and then eventually i'll get to where i
can actually listen to and understand
the story when i'm away from the ipad
then i can listen in my car and that's
going to all help to sort of drive the
language into my brain so i'll just
continue doing it
uh
i should say that i received
first of all so i'm going to attack on
as a separate video the video that conor
klein did with me in ukraine
also i have a video of judith meyer
speaking hebrew she is one of the
originators of the polyglot polyglot
conferences and remember i just i
attended this polyglot gathering
in
bratislava
and judith put out a video of herself
speaking hebrew after 90 days and she is
tremendous i was just blown away so i
don't think i will achieve the level
that she achieved i just don't think i
have the time to put in and for whatever
reason i don't know what i'm going to
get let's put it this way i shouldn't
say i won't i'm unlikely in my opinion
i'm i'm resigned to the fact that i
won't achieve what she achieved but it's
it's tremendously inspiring to see what
she was able to achieve
and that represents a bit of a light at
the end of the tunnel so if i can
progress at least some of the way
towards what she achieved
i will be very happy so i think it's
it's i guess the lesson in all of this
is when we start into a language we're
discovering it there are no shortcuts
yeah we can look up a grammar thing or
we can look up something else or you
know go to sort of a collection of
greetings if all of a sudden we have to
greet someone and say how are you
but really it's a gradual process of
discovering the language it takes time
and we need to be patient
but we also need to be convinced that we
will eventually
achieve a meaningful level a
satisfactory level in that language
whatever that level happens to be and in
that regard i'm thankful to judith uh
who sent me the video and i'm gonna
leave a link to that video in the
description box so there you have it
hebrew alphabet my sort of
breaking my teeth on
starting into hebrew thank you for
listening bye for now
[Music]
you